what's going on reject nation Greg Albie
here hey everyone
John what oh you know this is my secret
identity surprise oh I don't know I
don't watch those Marvel movies and I
pretend to we're gonna watch the
Marvel's spider-man SDCC 2018 story
trailer today if you haven't seen any of
the reactions we've done for them very
much looking forward to this game I got
into gaming again this year before we do
that I wanted to mention on patreon with
you full-length TV show reactions weekly
Q&A is music video coverage and patron
of the day shoutouts so today comes for
Derek Mitchell boots Derek Mitchell
recently launched a YouTube channel
called tales from a rideshare driver and
it's a really fun channel he's telling
stories as he his lyft or uber driver I
think it's uber he's talking about all
the creepy crazy stuff he does to normal
people it is exactly what is needed in
times like this where everyone is just
so hypersensitive you need to get
opinions from a rideshare driver on how
to not be so sensitive the channels
really about I'm just trying to get you
more viewers buddy controversy sells so
go check it out link in description box
and hey let's watch this video
four days after bday I know a Yuri
I don't know feels like the end of the
world
maybe it is okay Peter Parker yes
how the hell are you
the city is in danger he needs our help
Oh
Miley
all right well call the play coach I
call miles Miley a costume nutjobs since
taking city apart piece-by-piece
ten I returned later
what an opportunity
yeah sure you get to them the more you
become a target right
the closer I get the better chance we
have to stop them good graphics era
silver sable and her team to shoot you
on son ha ha ha this city oh it's not
bad
[Music]
that cake bin that's like
new this is coming Pete
I mean who would have had a cellphone in
your your pockets or something the games
gal humor mixed in I mean I talked a lot
in the last video reaction we did it's
cool to see Mary Jane Watson here it's
cool to see Miles Morales and the Norman
Osborn this it was the mayor something
we got an actual plot description here
to the high stakes and Marvel's New York
escalate as mayor Norman he's the mayor
is willing to take no risks during his
re-election bid he hires silver sable
and her security force silver sable
international to restore order to the
city which includes stopping someone he
believes it's contributing to the mayhem
spider-man so silver sable you do get a
lot of in this trailer as well and she
looks like a badass bill and a haven't
here was wondering if that's gonna be
like your main boss basically and then
perhaps throughout the game you're gonna
have to fight the different members of
the sinister six or something like that
kind of like a metal gear almost I'm not
entirely sure if this is gonna be
following like one main villainous
storyline because they mean this is the
official story trailer and there's
silver sable over this thing but she
doesn't like too much of a real threat
she looks like a cool component to have
in here but she doesn't look the real
threat the other trailers gave us like
mr. negative you see kingpin in here I
mean for him to be fighting all the bad
guys maybe there's one giant storyline
and a lot of little missions in between
this one giant storyline or maybe it's
just doing a bunch of different stories
in this one video game is that not
really sure what the approach is either
way if you're a spider-man fan this
looks awesome and if you're not a
spider-man fan I'm sure this game still
looks great to you - this looks like a
great time what I really appreciate
about this story trailer I mean it's
like for a gameplay trailer that's
that's the [ __ ] that really is you have
done they're really amping up the
emotional stakes here Mary Jane being
very much included in this trailer good
to bring it back to the heart of Peter
which is usually with Aunt May and Mary
Jane it's cool to get an emotional heavy
trailer for this because one part of
what makes games like this so gripping
is if you have a strong emotional story
as well the gameplay is awesome and I
feel like the last gameplay trailer we
got during e3
revealed a lot of the emotional
intensity at hand and here you get a lot
of what Peter is fighting for the
context yeah what and coming out this I
feel like you know film or comic
adaptations for video games are always
you know the most well received and a
lot of times they can be cash gravity
and what's so cool about this is that it
really looks like they're putting time
and effort into making this a great game
and not just another spider-man game
sure so it's like you point out the
graphics I mean I was surprised to like
some of the graphics in this especially
only like character designs look really
sharp absolutely and yeah it looks like
there's like a fully involved story and
it looks like the action is gonna be
totally arousing like this looks like it
has the potential to be a great game as
well as a great spider-man game anyway
guys how excited are you for this
spider-man is finally coming to ps4 and
just like a month and a half less than
that or something right right around the
corner I can't wait for this game you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification about the
subscribe buttons are broken and check
us out on patreon got a lot of goodies
over there love to have you become a
patron